oh
in the parking lot today there was a
circus copier did tricks on the high
wire
a lady tried to give away a baby that
looked like a cat
there was a dwight impersonator and a
gym impersonator
a strong man crushed a turtle i laughed
and i cried not bad for a
day in the life of a dog food company a
real shame about it huh
yeah must really have you thinking
about what the older you get the bigger
the chances you're gonna die
you knew that ed was decapitated
he was drunk as a skunk he was flying
down route six
he slides under an 18-wheeler pop it
snaps right off
oh my god that is the way to go
instant death very smart you know a
human can go on living for several hours
after being decapitated
you're thinking of a chicken what did i
say
hey where's dwight you didn't hear
decapitated whole big
thing we had a funeral for a bird
i'm pretty sure none of that's real
you're not real man
where is creed creed quality assurance
your job i really think you screwed the
pooch
on this one creed because of you the
entire company
is in jeopardy every week i'm supposed
to take four hours and do a quality spot
check at the paper mill
and of course the one year i blow it off
this happens
yes hello creed braddon quality
assurance dunder mifflin scranton
i was supposed to meet with one of your
floor managers last week for a quality
inspection
and he or she wasn't there and i'm
trying to remember who it was
who wasn't there last week
debbie brown and which day was that
wednesday the 11th perfect the only
difference between me and a homeless man
is this job i will do whatever it takes
to survive
like i did when i was a homeless man
when i went over wednesday for the spot
check i got a call from debbie brown
saying she has an emergency dentist
appointment emergency dentist
appointment
now i'm told she told her manager she
had the flu
i'm a trusting guy but uh i just wish
debbie round had been there we gotta
caught this
i run a small fake id company for my car
with a laminating machine that i swiped
from the sheriff station
it's a beautiful morning at dunder
mifflin
as i like to call it great brat keep it
running
do i love being manager i love my kids
i love real estate i love ceramics i
love my job i love
wrestling find out what language this is
okay team building on this side of the
room
stanley phyllis jim ted elroy
and this side of the room pam meredith
phyllis
creed he never called a meeting
bo body bow body what does the first b
stand for what are we doing we're making
acronyms okay
what does the first b stand for um
business i like it
business good kevin all right theo
we need a new manager hang up
corporate needs you to find the
differences between this picture
and this picture indel has told us there
are at least seven
okay i already see one give him okay
they're the same picture creed i noticed
you don't have a resolution on the board
what's yours
i want to do a cartwheel but real casual
like
not make a big deal out of it but i know
everybody saw it this one stunning
gorgeous cartwheel how's it going i'm
having a little trouble motivating
one of the hardest parts about making
resolutions is keeping them
in fact most resolutions are abandoned
by february
or sooner yeah it's not a joke but
that's okay
because it's not about being perfect
it's about trying in fact why don't we
go around
and confess some of the ways that we've
already fudged on our resolutions
well i said that i would eat more
vegetables and i haven't yet
but it's okay i still have time since
last year i
ate none okay well my confession is that
today
i had a sip of coffee but that's fine is
it
yes because with all of your support by
this time next year maybe i'll be down
to
one glass of icy a week next year i mean
what is the point what is the point of
that
i made a resolution to floss and i did
it 1201
january 1st bam blood everywhere well
not all of us are michael freaking scott
what is wrong with you people can't you
stick to anything
erin i want you to go to the kitchen and
get me some vegetables
creed you say you want to do a cartwheel
nothing's stopping you come on old man
do a cartwheel well i can't i don't know
how you're just gonna somersault around
for the rest of your life and you know
what's gonna be on your tombstone
loser my tombstone's already made thank
you just do a cartwheel look at where
you're going
to be doing the cartwheel so look where
you're going to be placing your hands so
pick a spot
you ready to do this yes sir you know
what i'm going to stay here as long as
it takes
i really appreciate it i'm going to spot
you i spot you you don't
go i
did it you did the perfect cartwheel
okay good the rush that's all i had to
do all year
congratulations all right well
all right see you tomorrow oscar why
don't you take this opportunity to
officially
come out to everybody here however you
want to do it
go ahead stand up
i'm doing this for you yes i'm gay
and i didn't plan on sharing that part
of my life with you
today so whatever
can i sit down now i'm not offended by
homosexuality
in the 60s i made love to many many
women
often outdoors in the mud and the rain
and it's possible a man slipped in
would be no way of knowing you know what
don't even worry about it everyone was
so drunk
but no one even remembers what you said
i remember i blogged the whole thing
www.creedthoughts.gov.www.backslashcreedthoughts
check it out last year creed asked me
how to set up a blog
wanting to protect the world from being
exposed to creed's brain
i open up a word document on his
computer and put an address at the top
i've read some of it even for the
internet it's
pretty shocking
you